[Music]
so
[Applause]
dear ladies and gentlemen
on behalf of the fdth council europe
it is my great pleasure to welcome you
to the ftth conference 2022 in vienna
the wonderful capital of austria
after two years of uh covet pandemic
where we could only meet virtually and
amid a very challenging geopolitical and
economical context nowadays in europe
our industry has demonstrated its vital
importance for the resilience of our
societies and for our capacity to
prepare our future prosperity
very high capacity fixed networks are
the backbone of digital society
and full fiber is undoubtedly the most
sustainable and future-proof technology
to enable all digital applications we
will need in the years and decades to
come
now
as you know vienna is also known as a
city of
dreams because of its artistic and
intellectual legacy
shaped by mozart beethoven straus
sigmund freud
this conference will make you dream away
and explore the latest fiber technology
and deployment solutions
the overwhelming need for connectivity
and bandwidth is increasing day by day
rupert wood from analysis mason will
show you how average data usage grows by
more than 25 percent every day every
year sorry
every year
every year
both in downstream
as in upstream
so fiber access projects will serve more
and more consumers enterprises and
mobile transport at the same time
5g and ftth will go hand in hand and
fiber is the cornerstone of a successful
convergent strategy
for network operators
the future of wireless
is wired
now fiber to the home has been and will
be our target for the coming years
but that same technology serves nowadays
for connecting everyone
everywhere
in personal
or in more professional environment
more than 50 percent of households in
europe now have access to full fiber
networks
and while several countries are about to
complete their rollout plans
others are catching up rapidly
during this two-day conference we will
as always
launch and present our latest market
panorama
including the global ranking forecast
2022-2027
and fiber to the home fiber to the
building in rural areas
specific sessions will be organized on
countries where the bulk of ftth
deployment is expected to take place in
the years to
come overall we see a great momentum
the european commission as well as
member states are setting ambitious
targets
and private investors are supporting
this massive
rollout effort
our sector
is at the heart of the twin green and
digital transition
which is a top priority of the eu
we see public policies and the european
regulatory framework as very favorable
to the development of ftth networks
and we will take the opportunity of this
event to discuss more in detail
how they can be further enhanced and
implemented in member countries
we want the europe's digital decade
program
stating that every european household by
2030 should have access to a gigabit
network
to find its implementation which secure
and sustainable digital infrastructures
and we would applaud that at least 20
percent
of recovery and resilience facility
funds are dedicated to digital
transition
we are confident
but a lot needs to be accomplished
ftth deployment in rural areas remains a
challenge
in many countries and planning the
decommissioning of legacy copper
networks is still an important objective
for the years to come
on top of that we should now focus on
the level of adoption of fiber
and ensure that a higher percentage of
internet subscribers opt for full fiber
connectivity
and one of those key challenges is the
evolution of in-home broadband
connectivity
whether the last meters of the network
are wired or wireless this should not
become a bottleneck
and subscriber satisfaction increasingly
depends
on how the potential of fiber network is
maximized thanks to appropriate
solutions
in end user premises
talent management
is becoming a critical issue for
operators
for operators and network builders
considering current deployment forecasts
our woman in fiber initiative
is made up of a consortium of male and
female leaders across fiber industry
the fdth council recognizes the desire
to drive change
and address the important matter of
gender balance in the industry
we believe
that the diverse workplace that fosters
a level of playing field for all
contributes positively to the success of
a company
climate change and cutting emissions
are on the political agenda in bold
letters
legacy to fiber migration an evolution
to next generation technologies
will lead to increased traffic handling
capacity
while keeping energy consumption
limited
sustainability action plans in ftth
industry will be discussed
now although our industry is thriving
we remain acutely aware of the situation
in ukraine
a few hundred kilometers east of vienna
the ftth council is partnering with the
austrian ngo jugent eineveld
they have a booth in the exhibition hall
and rely on your generosity to further
support the people of
ukraine we thank you in advance for your
contributions
the ftth conference brings together
fiber to the home experts from every
european country and beyond
policymakers regulators network
operators service providers and
technology specialists
are here to discuss the latest
evolutions
of this exciting market
we do our best to offer you the ideal
environment for information sharing
and business networking and we are
delighted
to welcoming you again in person to the
world's largest fiber summit in the
center of europe
by the way i have been informed we have
registered more than 3
200 delegates
from more than 50 countries
besides our appealing conference
speeches and panels
enjoy the networking moments
and opportunities
as wolfgang amadeus mozart once said or
once quoted
the music is not in the notes
but in the silence between
now the ftth conference has a tradition
to conclude the opening speech
with a short video clip which summarizes
our common objectives
at the end of this video
we would like you to light up the fiber
torch you have found
under or on your seat
as a gesture of your commitment to ftth
you see
you can light it up different colors
different wavelengths
i'm not going into the technology now
different wavelengths we will capture
this on video and use it for future
communication
we first show the clip and then at the
end of the clip we all raise the fiber
to have really the nice gesture
i would say thank you for your
participation and i wish you a very good
event
[Applause]
share
exchange
communicate
after several years inventing solutions
for the future accelerating fiber
deployment
making fiber robust and reliable
we are creating a resilient link
a link that you can count on when all
else fails a link that unites us and
makes us grow a link that allows us to
move forward together to continue to
treat to imagine
and to innovate
to continue to meet and to come together
we have overcome so many challenges to
allow everyone everything
everywhere
to stay connected and we will go further
to make fiber more accessible more
widespread today more than ever
high-speed connectivity is a must for
the european economy to thrive we have
worked hard and accomplished much
together but there are further
challenges to come
revolutions in collaboration and health
home office and remote working 5g and
fiber convergence in-home broadband
experience smart cities and new
applications
we are making great strides in realizing
the connectivity of the future
we are rolling out a sustainable
technology for the planet and future
generations
technology with endless potential and
possibilities adapted for the world of
tomorrow a responsible technology and an
essential technology
for you
us
everyone
building together greater links
more powerful connections more robust
networks for today and tomorrow
our mission is to connect the future and
for this we need all of you
are you
joining us
welcome to the ftth conference 2022
[Music]
foreign